[Music]
started really early on it's really
strange cuz while we were dating he
never like physically pressured me to do
anything but within a few days of us
being married he was very coercive and
controlling and forceful even like
forced himself on me against my will
okay we call that
[Music]
rap good morning good evening good night
this is the Dr John delone show and I'm
John so glad that you are with
us talking about emotional health your
mental health talking about what's going
on in your home with your marriage your
dating kids whatever is going on I spent
the last two decades walking alongside
people and the wheels have fallen
off and what I do on the show is I I I
don't always know the answer but I'll
sit with you and we will figure out
what's the best next right step if you
want to be on this show give me a buzz
at one 1844 693
3291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go to John
deli.com
askk love to have you on the show hope
you're having a happy happy New Year
let's get right to the calls let's go
out to Phoenix Arizona and talk to my my
my Miranda what's up
Miranda hi what
up uh I'm just excited to speak with you
today thank you for taking the time to
talk to me of course I'm grateful that
you called what's
up well I have a question um and so I'll
just I'll tell you my question up
front um I'm going through the process
of uh a divorce I'm waiting for it to be
finalized and I'm wondering when it's
helpful to speak up about abuse and
marriage after divorce and I'm wondering
if I'm just better off living with the
truth in peace if I've left an abusive
marriage
I guess first out of the gate man I'm so
sorry that you had to live with
this thanks yeah it's it's kind of
awkward because a lot of people just
really don't know um I I I left earlier
this year and um I'm trying to focus on
rebuilding my life I've mostly just kept
quiet about it um especially from the
beginning of our marriage and have been
really protective of my ex in a
relationship I thought I think I guess I
thought that we could work it out
privately and like with marriage
counseling and um no one no one in his
side actually knows what happened or
what he's done and honestly I feel like
there are a lot of things I still don't
know um and I don't want to cause issues
or drama and I really don't want to hurt
people because I feel like it could be
really hurtful to talk about
things um and I'm not sure I'd even be
like heard or listened to but the reason
I'm asking is because I recently ran
into one of his family my friends and it
went really sour and I'm just kind of
shaken up and wondering if I did the
right thing by keeping
quiet I want to reframe that for you
okay is that
cool yeah um tell me about the abuse and
then I'll walk you through this
reframe well um it started really early
on it's really strange because while we
were dating he never like physically
pressured me to do
anything um but within a few days of us
beinged married he just was very
coercive and controlling and
forceful um you talking about
sexually yeah um and at one point even
like forced himself on me against my
will okay we call that
rape yeah
um and hold let me let me St right there
why does that why does
the why does using that word make you so
uncomfortable I think I'm okay with
recognizing that internally okay but
I've really struggled with
publicly or with other people using that
word because it doesn't reflect the
image of what people typically think of
when they think of rape and I don't want
to take away from other people's
experiences because I know this sounds
bad but I feel like mine's just not as
bad as some other people's and I don't
maybe that's the wrong response but
that's just how I feel I don't
know
I I I'm really not going to frame
anything you're saying as right or wrong
okay I don't want you walking around
with that sort of weight like I did this
wrong I will tell you that comparing
trauma is an exhaustive Fool's
errand it doesn't make you feel any
better and it doesn't minimize to your
body to your heart to your soul
the violence that was done to
you and having your autonomy
stolen from somebody who got up in front
of your friends and family and God and
says I do
forever is
um can be one of the most
uning it just dissolves your sense of
self from the inside out right
yeah and but listen hold on I want you
to hear at least on this phone call
yeah your pain and the hell you've been
through is yours and it's
real and I'm not going to going to do
disservice to you by minimizing it
okay okay if that helps you get through
the day on in a regular basis I honor
that your body has been trying to keep
you safe and alive in whatever ways it's
tried to figure out for the last however
many years that's
cool but on this show I want to honor
you enough by saying out loud what
happened and calling it by the right
names and not saying yeah but one time
this happened worse to somebody else in
a different way I'm not I don't play
that game loss is loss rape is rape
violence is violence abuse is
abuse
okay thank you
all right so continue go
ahead um well I went through all of that
and publicly just pretended like
everything was great while like crying
every day in private
and always talking really wonderfully
about him to both our families um my
family thought he was like the most
wonderful thing um and we were both like
away from our families we didn't have
our families around us and so it's a lot
easier to just kind act like
everything's okay and and then we we
went through um like 9 or 10 months of
counseling couples counseling some
individual counseling to over this
incident or just to generally try to
improve your
marriage regarding the abuse because I
just couldn't have intimacy again
because I couldn't feel safe you know of
course did he ever apologize say I'm
sorry I mean what was his posture this
whole
time that's a confusing thing because
throughout that process like eventually
one day I broke down like crying and
soing about how much he hurt me and
like tried to just shove it away and
move on but I couldn't and so that's
when we went to counseling and we also
talked about just in general our
relationship and communication but
specifically regarding what happened and
moving past that and developing intimacy
again um and he was apologetic at the
time and since then he's taken it away
and tried to say it didn't happen um but
yeah long story short initially through
that process things seemed good and
then about after after we stopped
counseling um about a little a year
afterwards or not a year afterwards a
year and a half ago I guess I'm sorry
it's
confusing um for a whole year after that
it was just chaos it was like he didn't
really care about me anymore he wouldn't
talk to me mentally emotionally connect
with me all these really strange
behaviors it was like something else was
going on I didn't know what was
happening um I was dealing with a lot of
medical issues at the time
and I kind of hit a point in that year
where I recognized I didn't feel like I
had autonomy and could make decisions
for myself and I don't know if it was
necessarily that I felt so much pressure
from him but I just felt like something
was off and I had this strange almost
like spiritual experience where I just
felt everything in my body and my mind
like aware of it and just like go and
not even like leave him just go like
there's something in your situation
that's off go and so in the process of
trying to evaluate what's going on in my
marriage I for like short periods of
time would stay with one of my close
Christian friends because I just
couldn't think clearly and I couldn't
process my emotions around him I just I
don't know why I think I just didn't
feel safe
to um and through that
process it just spiraled it's like the
behavior got so toxic and there was like
lying and gaslighting and triangulating
between me and our families and like he
built up all this chaos and made it just
a toxic relationship to even try to stay
in to try to be
build
and I was on the inside just like trying
to wait for God to change his heart to
be able to try to work things out with
him because I couldn't reason with him
um
um and it just it got really bad it got
to the point where like I could see him
enjoying seeing me crying I could see
him enjoying hurting me it got to the
point where he convinced me I was like
crazy and tried to like diagnose me with
like a paranoia disorder and like I
almost like was thinking about admitting
myself because I was like oh my gosh
there's something really wrong with me
and if it wasn't for my good close
Christian friends being like you
gaslighting you your concerns are valid
what's going on isn't okay I probably
would have considered really doing that
um and so when when is your how long
were youall married we were married for
a little over three years and when is
your divorce
final uh it could be any day now does
the in your divorce decree did you
disclose the
abuse I didn't I didn't tell my lawyer
about um
what happened at least until later in
the process and even then it was like
she's like you can
either sue him or not bring it up
because either way like one or the other
it just I don't know why but it just
didn't seem like it was going to be a
helpful thing okay and I didn't I was
away from him at that point so I wasn't
going to like file a restraining order
because thankfully I was safely away so
are you in contact with him anymore or
are you
done um mostly just like
finalizing uh the separation of things I
guess is that in
writing yes
okay if you have means not everybody
does I would hire somebody to do
that and are you staying in the home or
is he staying in the home yall selling
it what are you how's this how youall
splitting
up I'm really fortunate at this point
I'm actually living in a different state
from him okay so so what stuff do you
have to go
get I don't have to go get anything else
we've already like separated it all good
okay yeah
so
man you've just been through it
huh that's like just one part of the
piece yeah yeah um well I was about to
say you've left out a whole bunch
yeah
yeah yeah and I can tell because you
have very circular evasive language that
I it's a very particular way of talking
that I only hear from people who are in
deeply abusive relationships it it was
real bad wasn't
it it's confusing because like no hold
on hold on I'm not gonna let you do that
it was real bad wasn't
it yeah it got real bad okay
yeah here's what I need you to know
okay you did everything you could to try
to make this thing
work even to the point that it got so
unsafe for you that your body said if
you're not going to leave I
quit
okay yeah you weren't going crazy your
body was saying I'm out because you
don't get the message that we're about
to get Ked killed
here we're living with a
rapist we're living with
a absolute
psychopath and because you wanted to
fulfill the role that the picture you
had in your mind you were so caught off
guard because this wasn't who the guy
this wasn't the guy you dated because
the family things were so nice and they
like everybody performed so well the
family get togethers and the friend get
togethers
and because you wanted to fulfill your
um whatever your faith told you your job
was as a married
woman you went into autopilot until your
body said I'm
out does that sound
right yeah I
think I I didn't see away out when I was
in it I know I
know but here's what I need you to hear
me say real irly until you tell the
truth to yourself your body's going to
continue to not trust you to drive and
it's going to drive for
you okay and what that means is you're
going to walk into a meeting and all of
a sudden your heart is going to start
beating 190 beats a minute and your
stomach's going to drop and you're going
to feel so sick and you're not going to
know
why and you're not going to be able to
sleep you're not going to be able to
meet people you see what I'm saying
those are all things that are happening
right
yeah I really struggle with this
Association I know that's your body
saying oh you're not driving I'm
out yeah
okay a lot of that starts with telling
the truth around language and telling
the truth about what actually
happened sitting down with somebody
you've heard me say it a million times
on the show grief Demands a witness I
got to sit in front of somebody else and
say the words my husband rap
me my husband was wildly
abusive I know my husband was cheating
on me because of X Y and
Z my husband did this and he did this
and you have to say those things
okay with a safe and trusted person now
here's the rub I don't have a good sense
and we could talk for a while longer but
in if we were in a different context but
I don't have a sense that
family friends or his friends or his
F I don't know what benefit there is to
bringing all this up the divorce is
final you're out of their life they
don't get a vote into your life they
don't get to speak into your life they
don't have anything to do with your life
and that lying piece of crap is going to
tell them whatever stories he's going to
make up about you and about the
situation and what a victim he is and
there's not a story I don't believe that
you can tell that they're going to go we
knew it is that fair
probably because the way this usually
plays out is the world looks at the
woman who got victimized and chose to tr
chose silence to keep safe it wasn't
because you were a coward it's because
your body determined you determined the
safest thing for me to do right now is
to be
quiet the outside world says well if it
was so bad why didn't you say something
why don't you tell us oh because she's
embarrassed she's just making this up
you see what I'm saying
yeah and they don't get a
vote they don't get a vote so I'm asking
you what what benefit would I me who
would you tell what benefit would come I
do see a significant benefit to sitting
down with your family
100%
I haven't spoken with his family but
I've tried to talk to my family and I
think
I think only really my brothers are very
supportive um the women in my family
have been really
toxic
why
um well
um I don't know there's it's it's hard
for me to understand too but there's
history of abuse and enabling abuse in
the past and so it to think of me being
the one that broke my marriage and left
irresponsibly is easier than thinking
that I was a victim in a situation for
them so they've they've been married to
abusive people and chosen to
stay um no they've enabled me to be
abused in the
past ah
gotcha so they've opted out of your life
too yeah my mom basically tried to deny
past abuse that happened right in front
of her and then told me because you said
that was abuse I don't believe you when
you tell me other things are Abus wow
okay are you seeing a professional
counselor I am yeah yeah I am I'm
actually excited to try and start EMDR
sometime good in the next few months
good hopefully that is an excellent
excellent excellent um modality for you
to help deal with this trauma um here's
the deal sitting with a professional
counselor I mean you got a you got a
hard row ahead of
you but pretending or to keep you safe
and not have to deal with the reality of
some of this by using some what I would
call pacifying language or circular
language like yeah it was really hard um
he made me feel uncomfortable versus
saying what actually happened the words
your body has to know that you are back
in control and the more that you deny it
the more you try to circle around it the
more your body's like oh she doesn't get
the severity of this
thing until you sit down in front of
somebody whether it's your attorney
whether it's your whether it's your
therapist and you say this is what he
did and while we're here this is what my
mom did this is what the man my stepdad
did and when I brought it up they made
fun of me they mocked me they said
that's not abuse oh
my and whatever whatever whatever
amen I hate this for you so much given
the fact that you have experienced abuse
before and you told your mom and she
didn't believe you it doesn't it makes
perfect sense that your body thought oh
this is happening again we can't tell
anybody because that that is not how
this problem is solved this problem is
solved through silence and compliance
let's try that cuz the last time it cost
us our mother and I need you to hear me
say none of this was your
fault none of this was your fault
hope you will sit in the presence of
some
trusting quality professional
professionals and that your
brothers some friends at your in your
new
community will be trusted safe resources
for you grief Demands a
witness I'm sorry marand we'll be right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow hallow is the number one Prayer
app in the world on planet Earth and
they're giving you three free months to
get start Ed and people always say you
got to meditate you got to pray you got
to have a spiritual life and for many of
us we don't even know what that means we
don't even know where to start that's
where hallow steps in three free months
to prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the LOI station that I love guided
prayers meditations and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life to figure out
what you even believe in the first place
and choose peace and remember Hall is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial that's hall.com
dealone all right we're back let's go
out to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and talk
to Christopher what's up
Christopher hi Dr jalone thank you so
much for taking my call I appreciate it
you got it man what's
up
so I want to help my brother
out um he's fought a long hard battle
with
alcohol and I've just noticed recently
in the past several months it's just
gotten worse and worse and worse and he
hasn't hit a rock bottom Point yet but
several several members of our family
have tried to talk to him and it nothing
is getting through to him and I just I
hate seeing this happen to him and I
want to know how I can help him if if I
can yeah man he's uh he's lucky to have
you as his brother
man it's pretty pretty amazing do you
live in the same Community as
him uh we're two towns apart but you
know within about a 20 30 minute drive
okay great um what have people tried to
do how how has that conversation
gone I know my parents have talked to
him I I don't know what the conversation
was my unfortunately my side of the
family is not open communicators okay um
so I know they tried talking to him and
tried convincing him didn't get anywhere
um his wife tried bribing him after you
know talking to him several times she
tried bribing him by buying him a big
present if he stopped drinking and of
course you know that probably lasted a
few days yeah that doesn't work doesn't
work oh man no and every every time I
see him now he's like slurring stumbling
yeah you know even in the middle of the
day okay so he's when you see him he's
actively
intoxicated yeah okay so here's a couple
of rules of thumb when I'm talking to
somebody who's struggling like this
okay um number one I can't make anyone
listen I can't make anyone do
anything and therefore I'm not
personally responsible for what choices
they
make right it's one of the scariest
hardest truths to
internalize
okay yep um hang on one second Kelly
have I asked talked on this show about
my dad and the SWAT stuff and listening
and falling
um I don't believe so okay Chris I'm
going to give you a what is a very
tragic truth um but one that is
something I live by okay it was taught
to me by my dad my dad was a SWAT
hostage negotiator um and so one of his
jobs when somebody was way up on a
building uh on top of building and they
were going to jump okay um he would go
up the elevator in let's say it's in a
giant hotel he'd go open the elevator
and he would get out of the elevator by
himself and he would always take a knee
and he would
pray and then the question they would
ask himself is watch or
listen and the reason he would ask
himself that is he was prepping for if
this person decides to go ahead and jump
despite his best
efforts and that simple question
provides a little little bit of
psychological space that lets me operate
without knowing that I'm not Tethered to
this person does that make
sense yeah put some psychological
distance so you can have a more
objective VI there you go because if
every time you see him you think it's
your job to save him you're G to end up
drowning
yourself so remembering and
internalizing I can't make him hear me I
can't make him do
anything he is making an adult Choice
okay so that's number one number two
there is no conversation to be had when
someone's intoxicated
period period the first 20 years of my
career I spent working with intoxicated
college students and I first would sit
there in their rooms with the police
officer and we'd have these long drone
out conversation by the time I'd been
doing it for five six seven years I
switched I would if they were safe I'd
tell them to go to bed if they were not
safe they would go to the hospital um if
they had broken the law they'd be
arrested and I would always tell them we
will meet tomorrow at 11:00
a.m. because you can't you can't hear a
word I'm saying right
now right right so that's number yeah
that's number two they you can tell them
y'all can have the most heartfelt
beautiful souls connecting conversation
but if they're not sober that
conversation's not getting through yeah
short for memory shot right it's just
there just everything right yeah so
here's what you can do oh here's the
third thing when somebody is this this
struggling this deeply with
alcohol I don't want to ask the question
why won't you quit
drinking I want to ask the question what
in the world happened in your life and
is continuing to happen that this is the
best way your body has figured out how
to get through a
day because that answer is
where the solution
lies okay it humanizes a person in front
of you as you're watching them just
struggle
right so here's what you can give him
you can give him an environment and a
relationship where he is able to listen
if he chooses
to so what does that look
like if this was my brother I would do
two things I would write a short and
very clear and simple letter that begins
with dear brother I love
you and what I'm hoping is in a moment
when he wakes up and he's sober and his
body feels like absolute run over by a
truck hell and before he reaches for a
bottle he's able to read
dear brother I love
you
okay the next part of that letter would
be something along the lines
of when you're ready to be well when
you're ready to get help I am here and I
will go to the ends of the Earth I will
run through hell for my
brother and it's short and it's sweet
and it's very very
clear and then I would be about inviting
him out hey do you want to come have
breakfast with me I'll only have it if
you're sober if you're not sober then
I'm not going to I'm not going to do it
so you get to choose but I really want
to go to breakfast with
you I had thought of trying to get him
to a neutral place like a coffee shop
that's right you know in the morning
when he's hopefully not started yet and
you know have that conversation with him
do you think it would make sense to
deliver the letter at that point
absolutely yes okay and I would tell him
maybe with a smile on your
face I felt like I needed to write my
brother a love letter and let you know
that I love you and if you don't say
that in your family sounds like you have
a family that doesn't share their
feelings and emotions very often this
might be super awkward yeah it will be
and I think you plow right through that
awkwardness and look him dead in his
eyes and say I'm your brother and I love
you okay okay can I throw a wrench in it
wrench it all
up I fought the same battle for you
years okay are you sober
now no okay I I was for last winter okay
um that fell off the fell off the rails
over uh last spring and uh I'm ready to
jump back on again awesome so
so have this conversation feels a little
bit
uh you know to faced you know not at all
I want to help you while I'm still
fighting the same battle no man in fact
in a strange way it gives you um a
little bit of uh empathy and
credibility I'm going to a meeting
tomorrow and I'd like to pick you up and
take
you and you can look across the table
because both of y'all went through it
when y'all were little didn't
you yeah we both started early High
School age that's right CU you had
to and we don't talk about this enough
in the addiction communities but the
alcohol worked it kept you two alive
didn't
it in a weird sort of way I guess that's
right it worked and now it's got you and
now it's time to
stop I realized at one point that I had
gone from Recreation to medication and
that's what I knew I had to do something
about it when you're drinking as a young
kid and your brother is too it's always
been
medication just the medication sto being
fun it's always been medication and for
whatever happened dude I'm so sorry that
y'all had to live like
that and I'm I'm I'm other planetary
proud of
you for saying enough is enough I'm
done thank you it's
hard and good god dude you're doing it
in the black hole of a Pittsburgh winter
for crying out
loud I'm gonna get sober with no son
good job Chris good
job but I think there's something
powerful about writing your brother a
love letter here's the other thing
there's something powerful about writing
14-year-old Christopher a love letter
too
because that kid's life has been
tough It's had its
challenges that's the most I struggle
with addiction thing I've heard all
day I'm I'm happy that I've been
blessed that I've never hit rock
bottom and nothing serious has ever
happened because of my drinking but I
know I've burned
relationships and lost
time I just want it to be in my rearview
here we talk a lot about Rock Bottom
dude but there is rock bottom and if
you've ever been have you been to
meetings
before yeah yeah you hear you hear the
atomic Rock bottoms that happens but
dude I I just don't think most people
make the transition I out of Rock
Bottom I think for most people Rock
Bottom is they live underwater in their
own
life their whole life is lived under a
mattress like Fight Club it's just a
copy of a copy of a copy nothing tastes
good nothing sleep isn't good sex isn't
good marriage isn't good it just
is and you just deserve so much freaking
more than
that there's so much Beauty in the world
and everything doesn't have to be shades
of brown and
gray and so there is this big rock
bottom I'm glad you're not in jail I'm
glad you're not dead I'm glad you didn't
wreck a car or kill somebody of course
but man I'm equally
heartbroken that you wake up every day
and you look at your watch and you think
12 more hours I can climb back into this
bed and call
it
that's not quite that bad I
know but the the whole you know every
evening you know crack the first one
open crack the second one open and
continue
until know I end up finally falling
asleep it's just that's right I can't do
it anymore that's right and I'm proud of
you for this
moment I'm proud of you
now you just got to make the next right
step as they
say but I think there's something
powerful about telling your brother hey
me too and I love you and I'm going to a
meeting tomorrow because I have to be I
have to be done that means I'm gonna
have to face My Demons head
on and I'd love you to be sitting right
shoulder-to-shoulder with me facing him
too and if you won't go just give him
the letter and let him know that I'm
there when he's ready whenever you're
ready I'm
here
yeah and then you're GNA walk the you're
gonna walk the walk
right yeah or walk the talk I guess is
what they
say will you call me in 30 days when you
get your
chip I
will yes I will if you call me a 30 days
and give me a chip I'm going to make a a
monetary donation to a local Addiction
Center in my community on your with your
name on it okay that' be awesome thank
you and I'll carry that all the way
through until you get one year chip
that's my commitment to
you I appreciate that Dr John thank you
you in are you
in yeah I'm ready
okay I'm proud of you brother hang on
the line um Jenna is going to hook you
up with um
a couple of different things she's going
to hook you up with both of my
books she's going to hook you up with um
I don't know many people who are
wrestling with um addiction who aren't
also do also have chaotic Financial
lives and it happened to just work at
Ram Solutions where they help people get
out of debt so I'm going to hook you up
with the financial piece series for free
and the every dollar app that will help
you make a budget and begin to get some
control back in your life there's
something about leaving uh your first uh
your first 12-step meeting and there's
that relief and then there's that oh God
I got to face the music well I want you
to have tools in your hand to face the
music okay so I'm going to hook you up
with that stuff as well so hang on the
line here and Jen will get you taken
care of I'm proud of you today this is
your Independence Day this is your day
of where you of Freedom where you begin
solving and choosing Freedom I'm proud
of you my
brother I look forward to hearing from
you in 30 days we'll be right
back I'm I'm always getting asked if
there are any new productss that I've
run across that are changing the game
for anxiety worry focus and sleep and if
you've listened to this show I'm always
telling you that technology won't save
us because we don't need biohacks we
need to transform our nervous systems
through movement mindfulness nature and
so forth and while I still believe in
critically important lifestyle changes I
have discovered a new wearable that is
literally changing my life and my
family's life I'm wearing it around my
ankle right now and if I didn't know
that it was the result of brilliant
neuroscientists and Technology experts
working together I would think this
device came straight out of Hogwarts
It's Magic I'm talking about Apollo or
also known as the Apollo wearable you
can wear it on your wrist like I said
I'm wearing mine on my ankle you can
just clip it to your shirt and it
actively improves your health by
transforming and strengthening your
nervous system it doesn't just measure
your health in Fitness it changes you
for the better Apollo delivers gentle
pulse vibrations that feel like your
body is experiencing the Rhythm and
beats of different songs these higher
vibrations help improve energy and focus
while lowering vibrations reduce stress
and help you relax since day one I've
experienced less stress more energy
relaxation and focus and get this my rim
sleep improved more than 90% from one
night to the next I know since wearing
Apollo I'm a better husband a better dad
and I can show up better for all of you
and my kids are getting in on the Apollo
too you cannot improve your marriage
your relationship to your kids or how
you show up in your community if you're
not sleeping if you're riddled with
anxiety and if you're not able to focus
along with making changes about how you
choose a non-anxious life the Apollo
wearable is a GameChanger that can
accelerate your healing Journey go to
apollon neo.com
backone or go to apollon neo.com and use
promo code deloney at checkout for 15%
off your purchase it's changing my life
and it can change yours
all right we're back let's go out to
Dear Marie in Pennsylvania what's up
Marie hi Dr John thank you so much for
taking my call today of course thanks
for calling what's up well um I have
less of a question and more just asking
for help I gotcha Let's Do It um just
needing some help dealing with some
feelings I'm having recently um my
daughter just got married about a month
month
ago and um we absolutely love our
son-in-law and we're so happy for them
we had a great wedding a great
celebration um but I'm as soon as the
celebration ended I began feeling this
immense sense of sadness and
grief um almost over like a loss and
I've just been having a hard time coming
to terms with that and trying to
understand why I'm feeling the way I'm
feeling man I'm smiling right
now and here's why because most of the
parents I talk to these days have no
relationship with their
kid okay and you love
yours I do more than anything what made
your relationship with with your
daughter
special well I can give you a little bit
of background because um although all
parents think their child is special I
really mine is special here we go Marie
I'm just kidding here we go go ahead
well just to give you some background um
my daughter was born with um a set of
very rare and complicated heart
defects and 26 years ago when she was
born uh we were told at that time you
know there's things that can be done um
to help her but there's very good
likelihood that she won't survive to her
first
birthday so we did all the things that
they told us to do multiple heart
surgeries procedures therapies lots of
hospital stays she made it to the first
birthday and she made it to the second
and the third and so
on so um over the course of her life
lots of other things have happened but
overall she's been able to not just
survive but really Thrive and better
than we had ever been told she would be
capable of and we're so grateful by the
grace of God that that she has had the
life that she has had so you know she
grew up she went to college she
graduated with honors and she's great
career in health care right now she's
back in grad school working to advance
her career and she really has had you
know what we had always always wanted
for her a a normal life despite her
health condition she's had some recent
challenges on top of her heart disease
she about three years ago is diagnosed
with a pituitary
adenoma so she's getting treated for
that as a result of her heart condition
she has liver uh therosis we're dealing
with that but as I said she's just had
this you know god-given life that we're
so blessed and I should be really happy
that you know she has gone on to make
all of these achievements and have this
perfect life and find the man of her
dreams and the week after her wedding I
was cleaning her room and rearranging
the furniture because I was so sad okay
hold on you're not sad that she's
married that's not what you're grieving
no you lost your
job some gross hairy-legged boy took
your
job and in doing so he took your
identity because you haven't taken a
full breath in 26 years have
you I tried to but you haven't taken a
full breath in 26 years and now you just
passed her over to this boy that says
I'm
in right I cannot think of a harder
thing for a parent to do other than to
bury a child than what you've
done so your grief and your sadness that
now you're in search of a new identity a
new role like a new a new
thing because you've been on call for 26
years
right right I feel that I do so give
yourself a minute okay give yourself a
minute and your purpose has changed and
your role is changed you're still mom
you'll always be mom and if anything
tragic happens and let's be honest she's
got a lot of challenges ahead of her
right yes of course so
um I want to say it this way and tell me
if I if I'm misguided or wrong okay
okay can we can I just can I just speak
as openly and direct as possible is that
okay absolutely okay you've been through
enough that you can just you can just
hear it straight right oh yes absolutely
okay sorosis ma heart
issues
um like there's a lot of mileage on her
sweet body right yeah a lot of Challenge
and repair and surgery her body's
already tired and she's 26 years old
right right for
25.9% of those years you've dealt with
that fragility by hanging on real
tight and you'll beat every single
marker that they gave
you and also you know time is is fragile
and short
right yes I do okay you know that in
your soul and you took your hands off
the wheel you had
to because she said mom I want him to
drive as she should right and so there's
that chaotic Reckless moment not
Reckless that's wrong word there's this
chaotic terrifying scary
moment where you send your kids out to
the Wild and in this case you know what
the Wild's going to
ultimately how it's going to ultimately
end
yeah and so instead of trying to make
yourself feel better by holding your
hands so tightly around her that she
couldn't
move you did one of the noblest most
amazing things a mom could do in this
situation which is let your
daughter make adult
choices and go live a wild Reckless
Love and work a w work a wild
job
and I got to rearrange the furniture
because I'm just going to weep for a
while Fair
yeah yeah I you know and and I always
thought you know that I wasn't holding
on too tight because you know that was
something I didn't want for her her
whole life I didn't want her to be you
know this weird sick kid all the time um
so I always sort of prided myself and
being the mom that you know let her go
and do things that were were scary and
dangerous um given her condition but I
wanted her to live life you know I
always said if her life was going to be
short it was going to be great God hold
on hold on hold on do you realize how
amazing you
are I'm serious listen oh my
gosh what an amazing mom you are thank
you and that sounds so awesome on
Instagram and that's sucks when you're
living it out every day right it's hard
it's so hard
hard but here's what you're doing in
real time and most parents in our
current culture cannot do this I hope
you hear me getting all fired up man
it's like making it's bringing me so
much joy okay most parents in our
current
world I'll just it's current world in
our current
culture use their kids to prop up their
own
Egos and you are not doing
that you are saying no I am GNA do what
I can to keep you safe and keep you
alive so that you can run wild and free
and your run is not going to be as long
as the kids you went to college with we
all know
that but I don't want to have gently
walked to the Finish Line with you
holding your hand the whole way and
making sure you didn't stub your toe and
we get to the Finish Line that's not
what I'm doing
I want you to
run right and and I've I do feel that
way and I always have felt that way and
and then and then she got married and
now I'm like
okay now what do I do yes so here's
here's I I want you to be really
specific you're not you're not grieving
her wedding I don't believe that I think
you're really in your soul so happy and
I don't know who this boy is but but
what an amazing
man what an amazing man he really is um
so I don't think you're grieving the
wedding I think you're grieving Your
Role has changed
dramatically and that's okay and so I
want you to feel permission to spend
time being incredibly
sad that's
okay I don't want you to use your
daughter as a Xanax to make you feel
better though you're the you're the mom
you're the adult so it's going to be up
to you to go hang out with your friends
go exercise go on a trip go do whatever
you need to do to stay whole and well
right hopefully it's constructive things
not destructive things but it's your job
to be sad that I mean that's feel fully
full permission to do that okay okay
you're not crazy there do something
wrong with you okay okay and then at
some
point the ultimate healing part of this
is as David Kessler says you're going to
go make meaning of it what do that what
does that mean in real life that sounds
all lofty I'm GNA go make meaning here's
what it here's what that actually means
with with skin and Knuckles on the
ground here's what this
means it means why
you why did the cosmos the universe or
God why did they give you this beautiful
young
girl to raise and protect and send out
to the wild why
you and what are you going to do with
that are you going to be a mom that runs
a Facebook page for parents who find out
their kids have some really difficult
medical needs are you going to be the
mom that brings um kids with special
needs from college over to your house
over the holidays and serves
Thanksgiving dinner long after your
daughter has
passed are you going to be like what how
are how is the world going to be
different because of what you've learned
and what you've experienced that's
making meaning it doesn't have to be a
grand
gesture but it can be right right but
that's not for today it's not for today
most people skip the being sad
part and what they do is they create a
kinetic hurricane of of of
activity and they help a bunch of people
and they are so hollow inside you can
you you know they they blow over with
the slightest
wind so unfortunately for you and your
husband you'll have to feel
this
right I don't think my husband's feeling
it the way I am though I promise he is I
promise he
is he he doesn't say uh he he thought I
was kind of overreacting over the last
couple weeks as I had been sobbing over
her Barbie dolls in her bedroom oh you
tell him to park it you're
overreacting
whatever his moment will come his moment
will come but here's the deal everybody
reacts to this stuff differently
everybody Grieves differently as David
kler says grief is like a fingerprint
everybody does it
differently but your role has changed
your purpose has changed no I don't know
your purpose is I'm going to continue to
love my baby
just what that looks like is going to be
different now cuz love used to look like
staying up all night making sure that
heart monitor was still beating love
used to look like walking far enough
behind her that she felt autonomous but
close enough you could catch her if she
fell and for a long time love look
like singing her way to college but then
keeping up with her checking on her
grades making sure she she was okay and
then love looked
like planning a
wedding and now Love's going to look
different it's going to look
different and as my favorite poet step
Connell
says love looks like come what come I'll
be right
here and you get to decide what that
looks like and may be a fun conversation
after your daughter gets home from her
honeymoon or kind of the Smoke Clears a
little bit you take her out and say
honey I have been trying to keep you
alive for so long how can I love you in
this new
season cuz you're a grown woman now
you're all married up ew
ew but you get to be sad
Mom I wish the world had more mares in
it it's such an honor that I got to talk
to you today we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
alone.com
all right we're back Kelly we're just
talking off air so you have a son that
you've worked through lots of challenges
and special needs right um and he'll be
18 today say actually his Gotcha Day
what's that mean that's the day he's
adopted okay got so today's his 16th
there you go see you just did it today's
his 16th Gotcha Day um but he'll be 18
here in a few weeks and the fact that
one of these days some other woman's
opinion will matter more than me when
he's sick when he's hurt when he's happy
sad he will go to some other
woman it kills me I can't
fathom what that will be like and that I
I have to be okay with it because that's
what's right so shortly after we brought
him home I apologized to my
mother-in-law because I was like I don't
know how you do it that all of a sudden
one day I won't
be the most important anymore and that's
how it's supposed to be but I'm not okay
with
it and one day he'll have a medical
Challenge and you'll get to call
while he's in route you won't get the
first call
[Laughter]
right
ah it's just I heard it's that cheesy
saying to have kids is like having your
heart walk outside your body it's so it
is so true because it's
just mine mine devastating but it's what
I mean like right now I'm you know Dad's
cooler than me because he's supposed to
be learning how to be a man this is
what's supposed to be happening but when
he's sick like he was sick not when he
had his wisdom teeth out last week come
and lay in Mom's lap you know lay down
with Mom that's because you were
sneaking his percus said can you know
make me soup mom you know it's just that
mom's like the safe place and and it's
just devastating that that's how it is I
um so Josephine and I were out somewhere
recently
and something happened to where she got
behind me and really
close and was holding on to my hand
behind my back it was kind of a a a
moment like it was nothing went down but
it could have and she sensed it before I
did and she got real close and got
behind
me and it was right and I remember
thinking in this
moment there is no person on this place
planet that can come through me to get
her
period and then I got all choked up on
the way home while we're listening to
Taylor Swift whatever nonsense she was
singing along to in the
back because I'm gonna have to hand that
over
someday it's it's just devastating
doesn't even it doesn't even it's not
right because it's right right this is
exactly what I can't be that weird
mother-in-law you know and I had a
fantastic mother-in-law but
it's just
so to one day think and especially when
you have to make them watch them make
bad choices and wrong decisions when I
think back I had long hair and a bunch
of earrings and I was like d it how did
they pass I don't know how that happened
it's it's so hard actually they didn't
pass my wife at all she's a grown woman
she didn't anybody to pass her
um
I I got to wrap the show up or I'm going
to start crying thinking about Josephine
so there we go all right so as we wrap
up Today's
Show we have a followup from Darcy in
Omaha Nebraska the original call Dang
Gina October of
2020 the world was spinning off of its
access during this call right yeah we'd
only been doing the show a couple months
at this time and we are right in the
middle of
covid lockdowns the whole thing so the
original call synopsis was left in abuse
of marriage with two small children her
son was very angry at his father and did
not want to spend time with him small
kid here's what Darcy writes I called
three years ago shortly after I left my
abusive marriage I had called because my
kids were scared to go to their dad's
home and I wanted to know what to do
wanted to share with John that we are
thriving today and it's because of his
encouragement it wasn't because of my
encouragement it's because you are made
some really difficult challenging Brave
choices my kids and I are seeking
therapy we're healing I'm finishing up
my master degree in education we're
close to being to not ow anybody owing
anybody any money and I was recently
promoted at my job my kids are
connecting with our community and sports
and finding friends at school it's been
a journey but it's one rooted in Hope
and Faith that God's greater plans for
us thank you for what you do I will
reiterate what I tell everybody when
they say you you did this for
me I run my mouth on a podcast or
YouTube show I literally don't do a
lot y'all at home who are deciding I'm
going to talk to my wife in a different
way I'm going to leave this abusive
marriage and I don't know where we're
going but I'm worth more than this I'm
going to endure and head into this
difficult season with my kids and we're
going to get this right y'all are doing
the work y'all are doing the work Darcy
I'm so freaking proud of you amazing
incredible everybody else out there who
is making changes in their life
keep going whether it's your Fitness
whether it's your weight whether it's
your marriage whether it's your you're
getting sober whatever it is keep going
so proud of you love you guys
bye